it's day five of the partial government
shutdown over border wolf funding and
both sides are refusing to budge
President Trump not backing down here's
what the president said just hours ago
in Iraq we need safety for our country
even from this step one we have
terrorists coming in through the
southern borders can we have some
grounds can we have technology
technology is bells and whistles you
have to have a wall you have that
protection so when you say how long is
it going to take when are they going to
say that we need border security what
are the Democrats going to say don't
forget the Democrats all agree that you
need a wall until I wanted it House
Minority Leader and soon-to-be Speaker
Nancy Pelosi is pushing back against the
president claiming quote he's using
scare tactics that are not
evidence-based and it's wrong former
acting ice director Thomas Holman is
responding to Pelosi by saying she's the
one who has it all wrong she's one of
her sent wrong so let me educate Miss
Pelosi as far as crime come across the
border ice arrested 138 thousand
criminals last year these are people
entered country illegally and committed
a crime against the citizens country
okay over 2,000 homicides over 11,000
weapons violation over 11,000 almost
12,000 sexual assault crimes sexual
crimes so crime does come across that
board they just didn't miraculous appear
United States to enter the country
illegally you know my take on this is
this is a huge opportunity to do
comprehensive immigration reform both
sides are dug in and positions I think
don't make a lot of sense for the
country and indeed even their political
positions wouldn't it make sense to do a
wall enhance border security offense as
the president talked about in exchange
for a path to citizenship for the
dreamers and some right for those of 10
or 11 million who are here illegally to
stay doesn't that make sense Dana well I
think so but I doing interfer to Katie
who was there for that interview this
morning and it was
Arizona I mean we've talked about
comprehensive immigration reform for
years over three different presidents
doesn't make it wrong no here's the
problem with comprehensive immigration
reform is it's too big of a project to
do when you have a serious crisis at the
border at this point in time border
security is different than amnesty for
millions of people who are either here
illegally or who brought their children
over when they were children without
having gone through the proper process
for citizenship and so when the
president talks about wanting a wall or
a barrier he's correct when he says that
where we built these things in Yuma
Arizona for example in places in El Paso
in San Diego the traffic there has
stopped and if you look at the criminal
element that is bringing these children
and these people up through Mexico and
using them as human shields to get into
the country you have to take a look at
the real issue of the law being changed
there and I've always said that open
borders are inhumane borders you had the
report today of the second child dying
while in border patrol custody that is
not a result of border patrol that is a
result of sick kids showing up at the
border in the United States giving them
care that they have not seen for 2,000
miles along their journey is okay it
complicates things
enormous ly when you throw in
comprehensive immigration reform when
the president is an emergency right now
look I agree with Katie but I think
you're not the miss but I tried well
you're not where your party is right now
I know you're very amenable but as a
relates to your party it's become an
open borders party and they have gone
from wanting to ban ice - and let me say
this the president tried to move on this
last week and he got a major blow back
and I said it last week the president if
he wants to lose his base this was the
moment that he was gonna lose his base
because he was caving and so now the
president is going to the opposite
direction and saying look I can't budge
on this I tried to go with my people
with this I tried to get some type of
reasonable approach they're not having
it and so the Democrats you got to give
me some wiggle room right here what you
guys want to put onto the table is let's
just talk about daca
well that doesn't solve the problem
that's on the border and we went through
this with Ronald Reagan before where we
gave you amnesty and said hey you got to
get border security and it never came
and so the American people just aren't
gonna go for Tom in my off-base well
where you were off base was adding those
10 or 11 million that's you know if he
wants to throw docker into some deal I
think people would go for it but they're
not gonna go with the broad and the deal
in 2013 included the 10 or 11 million I
got 68 votes in the Senate is more
complicated than just giving citizenship
to people who are brought here as
children from Mexico or Central America
because then the question is well if
their parents are still in the country
illegally do they could then get to say
it's a complicated issue of family units
and whether they get to stay it's not
just a simple piece of legislation there
are serious questions surrounding how
that gets done but when it comes to the
president what they have offered
incoming chief of staff Mick Mulvaney
was on Fox News Sunday over the weekend
and he actually said that they've come
down from there 5.7 billion dollars
worth or they did not say what the
number was but Democrats they're hoping
we'll come to some Center when it comes
to the funding and we're talking about
three billion dollars here and I think
the fundamental political position they
don't like the optics of the wall that's
what it is that but the president we
know you're not going to just get a
physical wall on all aspects of the
border they've called it the border wall
system he's talking about adding a
technology to it but the symbolic
measure of the president have an
accomplishment when it comes to the wall
is what Democrats are against right I'm
saying that's exactly right
there has to be a compromise around a
fence enhance border security and some
path to citizenship for the daca
residents notwithstanding the issue
that's a separate issue I don't
understand why Democrats keep lumping it
together because there's border security
and then that's taking care of the
people that are already here but you
can't talk about fixing a problem I'm
sorry
fixing a problem with the kids that are
here has nothing to do with the border
it's not I think that Democrats even if
I think if Barack Obama would have
decided to build a wall to stop an
influx of illegal immigration the dumber
crowds would have gone for breeding
gross autocracy between what Barack
Obama do and I should hammer that a
little bit more I mean because the
Democrats did vote for border security
fencing things that look like a wall but
it's it's not just the it's some
symbolism of the wall so a lot of this
is a political symbolism fight the other
thing is a shutdown right so far has
been a little bit symbolic now if you're
one of the nine hundred thousand years
being furloughed that's important that
is a big deal to you and they hope I
hope they can take comfort in the fact
that the government has done back pay
ever for them but the first real day of
the shutdown is actually today because
the president gave Christmas Eve as a
holiday as well so there's this is they
actually the first real day we'll see
what sort of pain comes but I think they
end up with like three point three
quickly isn't this ridiculous the whole
thing yeah shut down the fight all of
this yes is the worst I don't know I
don't know I think if he's I don't think
it's bad for the president to throw a
temper tantrum and say give me my five
billion or you're not going to get your
government back I think to me it's it's
that is a to me it's a bad mistake
politically and substantively okay we'll
see what you win